When you stop and think
about where you came from,
you most likely a reminded of your
mother or a street you grew up on.
But think about evolution and biology
class and the animal that we are closest
to the chimp.
There were based systems that control us
and these systems have been studied in
animals that date back much
farther than the monkey.
In fact,
the animal which gives us insight into
why base drives like status and hierarchy
are built in date back one
third of a billion years.
And if you've been following
Dr. Jordan Peterson,
you'll know exactly what
animal I'm talking about.
Yes,
you guessed it.
The lobster,
the display of status is something
that dates back thousands of years.
Let's look at the lobsters habitat.
It's a volatile place with many
lobsters struggling to hunt for food and
occasionally settling for scraps
that fall from the sky above.
If food wasn't enough to have to worry
about shelter is the next item to
struggle over.
And because shelter is so scarce,
lobsters have to resort
to the only method which,
which they know how to acquire things.
Dominance.
Now it's a fun scene that is painted in
the 12 rules for life of the physical
struggle for dominance among lobsters.
However,
for the sake of time,
I'll cut to the end of a fight.
Having defined a clear winner and loser.
Now it doesn't take a physical altercation
to mark a winner or a loser that is
largely governed by neuro chemistry.
The two chemicals that
governed the lobsters,
mood and behavior are
serotonin and October Jamine
Serotonin and I've Topa mean
exist in balance.
And when Serotonin is at a higher level
and October me lower the effect is very
confident.
Lobster of Mcgregor ready to
fight everyone type of lobster.
Also heightened serotonin makes a
lobster ready to fight and display its
dominance continuously and
as long as the lobster wins,
the serotonin levels stay high.
However,
if the lobster loses,
the inverse happens and an increased level
of October mean and lowered serotonin
occur leaving a very sad
er sort of lobster soaking
around too afraid to fight.
If a previous dominant lobster loses a
fight is once dominant brain transforms
into a new subordinate brain knocking
him down the hierarchy like with humans.
The spoils go to the dominant,
the prime real estate,
all the ladies and all the scrap food.
The dominance hierarchy is the other
biological structure built into us and all
other animals.
Yes,
builtin.
It isn't the result of social
constructs like capitalism,
communism.
It's not the military industrial complex.
It's not the patriarchy.
It's not a human creation.
The dominance hierarchy has been deeply
rooted for hundreds of millions of
years.
We saw it in grained in the lobster
brain and it is a permanent fact of life.
The human brain at a basic level shares
a similar neuro chemistry with the
lobster.
When a human loses a battle or
suffers a defeat or betrayal,
we often recoil and pull within ourselves.
If we stay down for long enough,
we become chronically depressed.
Serotonin that governs posture and fight
or flight reactions in lobsters has a
similar effect in humans.
Low ranking lobsters are like low ranking
human beings and that their behavior
is similar.
When levels of Serotonin are low,
low confidence,
costly.
Your stress response and being at the
bottom of the hierarchy generally means
more bad things can and will happen,
less happiness,
more pain and anxiety,
more illness and a shorter lifespan
and with higher levels of Serotonin.
The end verse effects occur.
Less illness,
less misery in depth,
a better income.
At an unconscious level,
your status is tracked at
the root of your brain.
If you're male and your status is high,
you have preferential access
to the best places to live.
The highest quality food people want to
socialize and will do anything to help
you.
You have limitless opportunity
for romantic and sexual contact.
If you're a female at the top,
you have access to many attractive,
creative,
reliable,
honest,
high quality men and
like the dominant male,
you compete ferociously,
even piddle Asley to maintain
or improve your position.
The opposite end of the diamond at the
opposite end of the dominance hierarchy
is a dangerous place.
No good places to live,
if any terrible food when not starving,
poor physical and mental condition as
you're a minimum romantic interest to
anyone unless they are
as desperate as you are.
The part of your brain
that assesses dominance,
watches how you were
treated by other people.
The part of your brain
that assesses dominance,
watches how you are
treated by other people,
how you are treated renders
your value and assigns status.
If you were judged to have little worth,
your brain restricts serotonin.
This makes you more physically and
psychologically reactive to any event that
produces emotion,
particularly negative ones.
That reactivity is needed,
where emergency is common,
constantly being alert,
burns up precious energy
and physical resources.
Also,
all emergencies will be tackled loan
because of the lack of quality social
network at the bottom.
You continually sacrifice what you
could otherwise store for the future.
Using it up on a heightened readiness
drug use and promiscuity and myriad.
Other things are used to cope with the
stress that habits can present serious
problems and what does the physical,
however,
it can be labeled and
mistaken as a mental illness.
The positive feedback loop that
alcoholism can create can be fatal.
Imagine someone who
enjoys drinking alcohol.
He has a few drinks and his blood
alcohol level rises and when he stops it
plateaus and begins to fall and when his
body starts to metabolize the ethanol,
he has a hangover.
Well,
most alcoholics at some point realized
drinking helps fight the hangover.
However,
postponing the withdrawal long enough can
be fatal when the cause of the problem
is also the cure.
Creating a positive feedback loop.
The problem can spiral out of control.
With depression,
a person feels useless and burdensome so
that'd become isolated and that intern
amplifies the depression.
Social anxiety often
cause from some sort of
social anxiety often caused from some
type of trauma like bullying can lead a
person to avoid eye contact,
be upset,
easily be certain or indecisive and take
a habitually submissive posture that's
observed by all and sometimes further
exploited by adults that have remained
Billie's into adulthood.
Some people become bullied
because they can't fight back.
For kids,
a six year old is no
match for a nine year old.
Women tend to be less physically
strong in the upper body than men.
However,
some people choose not to fight back.
The temperament of a person that's
bullied is commonly compassionate and self
sacrificing and high in negative emotion
and it doesn't help when they make all
sorts of noises that please
the sadistic no step dad,
her crying works especially well.
People who have had tyrannical parents
can become sensitive to tyranny and
overaggressive competitiveness
and restricted.
They themselves all the emotions
that might give rise to such things.
These people may decide that
all forms of aggression,
including feelings of
anger are morally wrong.
These people restrict their ability
to fight back and because of their
compassionate and self
sacrificing temperament,
which often turns out to
be naive and exploitable,
are unable to call forth
the genuinely righteous,
inappropriate,
self-protective anger
necessary to defend themselves.
If you can bite,
you generally don't have too.
When integrated properly,
the ability to respond with aggression
and violence decreases rather than
increases the probability that actual
aggression will become necessary.
If you say no early in the
cycle of oppression and mean it,
then you will limit its effect on you.
When naive people discover
the capacity for anger within,
they are sometimes shocked severely.
However,
when people recognize themselves
as dangerous there fear decreases.
They develop more self respect.
There is a little difference between
the capacity for mayhem and destruction
integrated and the strength of character
applying rule one standing up straight
with your soldiers back is made much
simpler by instilling a few routines in
your life.
Routines are necessary in many aspects
of life to keeping your brain functioning
properly.
Sleep is the first area that you want to
address specifically when you wake up.
Also,
you want to wake up around the same
time other people wake up around you.
The relevance of proper sleep
patterns is easily observable.
When you see the difference between
well rested and sleep deprived children
night and day.
Not only does sleep regulate
your security and rhythms,
but eating does too,
so alongside waking up at the same time,
eating at the same time
can be important as well.
What to eat is equally important.
High fat and high protein is
preferred to simple carbs and sugars.
Unlike fat and protein rich meals,
simple carbs and sugars exacerbate
existing physiological and psychological
problems and cause spikes and dips in
blood sugar that people identify as rushes
and crashes.
High fat and high protein diets leave
you feeling energized and more balanced
throughout the day.
If you feel like you're a loser,
maybe you are.
Maybe you aren't.
Regardless,
you don't have to be.
You may just have one bad habit
or a collection of bad habits.
You may have developed bad posture.
You may have been bullied or
unpopular at home or in school.
It's not necessarily appropriate.
Now,
circumstances change.
If you slump around like
the defeated lobster,
people will treat you as such.
Then your brain won't produce as much
serotonin which will make you less happy
and more anxious and sad.
Your probability of
living in a nice place,
finding a stable,
healthy mate,
your access to high quality
resources will decrease.
You will live for the present and not
defer gratification and you will be more
likely to abuse drugs.
Now I'm going to read a
few pages of Jordan's book.
You might object.
The bottom is real.
Being at the bottom is equally real.
Emir.
Transformation of posture is insufficient
to change anything that is fixed.
If you're in the number 10 position
and standing up straight and appearing
dominant might only attract the
attention of those who want.
Once again to put you
down and fair enough,
but standing up straight
with your shoulders back is
not something that is only
physical because you're not only a body,
you're a spirit,
so to speak,
a psyche as well.
Standing up physically also
implies and invokes and demands.
Standing up.
Metaphysically standing up
means voluntarily accepting
the burden of being your
nervous system responds in
an entirely different manner.
When you face the demands
of life voluntarily,
you respond to a challenge.
Instead of bracing for a catastrophe,
you see the goal,
the dragon hoards instead of
shrinking and terror from the all too,
real fact of the Dragon.
You stepped forward to take your place
in the dominance hierarchy and occupy
your territory,
manifesting your willingness to defend,
expand,
and transform it.
That can all occur practically
or symbolically as a
physical or as a conceptual
reconstruction.
To stand up straight with your
shoulders back is to accept the terrible
responsibility of life
with eyes wide open.
It means deciding to
voluntarily transformed the
chaos of potential into the
realities of habitable order.
It means adopting the burden of self
conscious vulnerability and accepting the
end of the unconscious paradise of
childhood where finitude and mortality are
only dimly comprehended.
It means willingly undertaking
the sacrifices necessary
to generate a productive
and meaningful reality.
It means acting to please God in the
ancient language to stand up straight with
your shoulders.
Back means building the Ark that
protects the world from the flood,
guiding your people through the desert
after they have escaped tyranny,
making your way away from comfortable
home and country and speaking the
prophetic word to those who
ignore the widows and children.
It means shouldering the
cross that marks the ex,
the place where you and
being intersect so terribly.
It means casting dead rigid and too
tyrannical order back into the chaos in
which it was generated.
It means withstanding the
ensuing uncertainty and
establishing in consequence a
better,
more meaningful and more productive order.
So at 10 carefully to your posture,
quit drooping and hunching around.
Speak your mind,
puts your desires forward as
if you had a right to them,
at least the same right as others
walk tall and gays forthrightly ahead,
dare to be dangerous.
Encourage the Serotonin to float
plentifully through the neuropathways.
Desperate for its calming
influence and people,
including yourself will start to assume
that you're a competent and able,
or at least they will not immediately
conclude the reverse emboldened by the
positive response.
As you are now receiving,
you will begin to be less anxious.
You will then find it easier to pay
attention to the subtle social cues that
people exchange when
they are communicating.
Your conversations will flow
better with fewer awkward pauses.
This will make you more
likely to meet people,
interact with them,
and impress them.
Doing so,
we'll not only genuinely increase the
probability that good things will happen
to you.
It will also make those good things
feel better when they do happen.
Thus strengthened and emboldened.
You may choose to embrace being and worked
for its furtherance and improvement,
thus strengthened.
You may be able to stand even
during the illness of a loved one,
even during the death of a parent,
and allow others to find strength
alongside you when they would otherwise be
overwhelmed with the
spare thus emboldened,
you will embark on the
voyage of your life.
Let your light shine,
so to speak,
on the Heavenly Hill and
pursue your rightful destiny.
Then the meeting of your
life may be sufficient to
keep the corrupting influence
of mortal disparate bay.
Then you may be able to accept the
terrible burden of the world and find joy.
Look for your inspiration
to the victorious lobster
with its 350 million years
of practical wisdom.
Stand up straight with
your shoulders back.